herzlich willkommen zur folge 188 des
faz einspruch podcast der wöchentlichen
podcast der faz für recht justiz und
politik heute am ersten dezember 2021
mein name ist corinna budras und mutter
weiß wieder markus
ja pia lorenz ist im urlaub und deswegen
wärst du uns mal wieder freut mich sehr
lieber markus ein gewehr oder viele
werden dich kennen du bist ja auch schon
häufiger auf in dieser sendung gewesen
aber vielleicht für die menschen die
hörerinnen und hörer die neu dazu
gekommen sind sagt doch vielleicht noch
mal ein paar takte zu dir ja also ich
bin wie du corinna mitglied der
wirtschaftsredaktion aber in frankfurt
angesiedelt und schreibe sehr viel über
wirtschaftsprozesse über den kanzlei
markt und natürlich auch über das
arbeits und sozialrechts und da haben
wir schon mal ein paar punkte skizziert
die wir heute auch in der sendung
wiederfinden werden ja genau dafür darum
wird es natürlich auch gehen wir steigen
aber erst mal ein mit dem
bundesverfassungsgericht dass ich
gestern ja endlich endlich geäußert hat
zur bundes notbremse da werde ich gleich
ein interview führen mit dem ein
verfassungsrechtler franz meyer den hier
auch schon einige kennen und dann geht
es weiter mit welchen themen markus dann
werden wir blicken auf einen anderen
wirklich mammut prozess der jetzt auch
seine endphase auf das ziel zuschauer da
geht es um das sogenannte deutsche
telekom verfahren um streitigkeiten von
kleinaktionären die deutsche telekom die
mittlerweile tage seit 20 jahren
anhängig denn vor den zivilgerichten und
da gab es in der vergangenen woche eine
mündliche verhandlung am
oberlandesgericht frankfurt ich war vor
ort und kann euch da die details auch zu
einem möglichen vergleich oder
vergleichen vielmehr die jetzt auf dem
tisch liegen dann gleich nochmal näher
bringen und
dann hast du ja schon gesagt du bist
auch im kanzlei markt bewandert und
erklärt uns mal in gehälter wahnsinn der
da stattfindet mal wieder ja also wir
dachten dass es vielleicht auch ein
thema was vielleicht auch für
nichtjuristen interessiert die
vielleicht auch nicht die ganze zeit
immer mit husten anwälten und so weiter
zu tun haben aber wie sich da der
gehälter markt entwickelt interessiert
er womöglich den einen oder anderen auch
so ja und dann haben wir natürlich
wieder ein gerechtes urteil der woche
genau und nach dem ja alles sich gestern
auf karlsruhe konzentriert hat hat das
bundesarbeitsgericht in erfurt gestern
nachmittag auch noch eine sehr spannende
entscheidung gefällt auch mit einem sehr
starken kroner bezug da geht es um das
thema kurzarbeit und deren auswirkungen
auf urlaubsansprüche gut aber dann
steigen wir doch mal ein
[Musik]
ja bevor wir gleich mit dem interview
weiter machen wollte ich noch die
gelegenheit nutzen das eine oder andere
detail zur bundes notbremse in
erinnerung zu rufen ist ja schon ein
weilchen her das interessante an der
bundes notbremse war ja dass sie zum
ersten mal so eine art von
automatismus einführte in paragraf 28
des infektionsschutzgesetzes waren
schwellenwerte benannt und zwar bei
einer inzidenz von 100 also wenn ich das
noch mal in erinnerung rufen darf geht
ja immer um 100
neuinfektionen mit dem corona virus je
100.000 einwohner innerhalb von sieben
tagen ja die berühmte sieben tage
incidents die uns auch bis jetzt nicht
loslässt so bei dieser schwellenwert von
100 überschritten war griffen kontakt
beschränkungen ganz automatisch also
ohne dass die landesbehörde die
landesregierung da neue verordnungen
lassen mussten flankiert war dass mit
diesen ausgangs beschränkungen die ja
auch extrem umstritten waren zu dem
damaligen zeitpunkt und ist ja auch
heute noch sind dann gab es die nächsten
schwellenwert bei 150 das waren die
berühmten click and meet regelung für
den einzelhandel die sich heute
irgendwie auch keiner mehr so richtig
erinnert also da durfte man nur in die
leben mit von mit mit vorheriger termin
buchungen und dann war natürlich noch
wichtig auch das späte jetzt eine rolle
vor dem bundesverfassungsgericht die
schulschließung wurden ab einer inzidenz
von
165 wirksam so und mit alldem
musste sich das bundesverfassungsgericht
beschäftigen und die beschlüsse schauen
wir uns jetzt mal näher an
[Musik]
und dazu darf ich jetzt den
verfassungsrechtler franz meyer in der
leitung begrüßen den ihr hier auch
sicherlich viele kennen hermann ja schön
dass sie sich die zeit nehmen schönen
guten tag ich
erst mal vorneweg im zentrum stand nur
einige aber dennoch zentrale maßnahmen
der bundesländer konkret ging es um die
kontakt beschränkung in verbindung mit
ausgangs beschränkungen sowie die
schulschließung herr meier sie dürfen
sich aussuchen womit wir anfangen
vielleicht klären wir mal vorneweg was
wurde denn eigentlich entschieden
ach es würde mich recht klar gesagt dass
das was da im frühjahr 2020 ins werk
gesetzt wurde mit der verfassung
vereinbar ist also die botschaft das
signal ist
eindeutig könnte es nicht sein
kein sondervotum und auf 170 seiten
insgesamt das sind ja zwei beschlüsse
also zusätzlich zwei entscheidungen
mit hinweis darauf dass man ganz viele
sachverständige auch zu rate gezogen hat
allerdings alles schriftlich eine
mündliche verhandlung hat es nicht
gegeben und wie ich finde sehr
erfreulich und auch durchaus hilfreich
auch unter heranziehung zahlreicher
rechts vergleichen der gesichtspunkte
ist die kernaussage letztlich wenn die
erkenntnislage unsicher ist wie sie 2020
war wie sie derzeit immer noch ist dann
gibt es erhebliche spielräume für den
demokratisch legitimierten gesetzgeber
und kurz die bundes notbremse war mit
der verfassung vereinbar erfreulich
deswegen weil das im grunde genommen
dann in die hände gegeben wird von den
leuten die auch gewählt wurden und nicht
das bundesverfassungsgericht sozusagen
der gesetzgeber spielt verstehe ich sie
richtig richtig also erstens erfreulich
weil es ein klares signal ist das ist ja
so dass diese sondervoten durchaus eine
funktion haben die können ja dann auch
den unterlegenen helfen so ein bisschen
das gesicht zu wahren so nach dem motto
schau mal hier gab es ein paar richter
design ist auch wie ich und die stadt
ihren ja manchmal auch künftige mögliche
entwicklungen der rechtsprechung vor
aber in der gegenwärtigen situation noch
mehr als sonst haben so die
gerichtsentscheidung natürlich auch eine
funktion weit über die entscheidung des
konkreten einzelfalls hinaus das ist das
eine und das andere ist dass wir
eigentlich schon die ganze zeit
beobachten dass die gerichte
merkwürdig zurückhaltend sind sagt
merkwürdig weil das eigentlich nicht
wirklich so der stilist mit dem wir
unsere gerichte kennen gelernt haben
normalerweise sind die gerichte durchaus
bereit auch selbst abwägung zu treffen
und wichtige entscheidungen und wichtige
entscheidung weil wichtige rechtsgüter
dann in die urteile auch reinzuschreiben
und in der anime meine ich beobachten zu
können dass es eine extreme
zurückhaltung gibt die ich so deute dass
die gerichte schlicht keine lust haben
diese schwierige abwägungen die nummer
zu treffen sind anstelle der politisch
und demokratisch verantwortlichen zu
treffen und das halte ich in der tat
dann auch für richtig wie sie sagen
diejenigen die demokratisch legitimiert
sind aber auch demokratisch
verantwortlich irgendwann wird es mal
wieder wahlen geben die sollen die
zentralen entscheidungen treffen die
zentralen abwägung und das ist das was
ich auch in diesem urteil als sehr
deutliche botschaft herauslesen
also im grunde genommen da wirklich eine
deutliche zurückhaltung nichtsdestotrotz
hand ja des bundesverfassungsgerichts
schon auch die gewichtigkeit der
eingriffe also deutlich gemacht hat ganz
klar gesagt also hier haben wir es ja
mit verletzungen zu tun in
unterschiedliche
grundrechte wir haben einmal dass bei
den schulschließungen das war ja auch
sehr interessant gibt es jetzt sogar
erstmals festgestellt ein recht auf
schulische bildung was verbirgt sich
dahinter hat sich das überrascht ja also
zunächst mal wie sie sagen es ist
einerseits zurückhaltung aber das ist
nicht gleichzusetzen mit
da wird einfach auf zwei seiten gesagt
macht mal sondern dem gericht ist das
kunststück gelungen sich in der sache
zurück zu halten und gleichzeitig wie
ich jedenfalls meine auf diesen 170
seiten diesen 170 seiten doch im detail
die verfassungsrechtlichen leitplanken
die es da gibt es sehr deutlich zu
machen und ein aspekt ist sicherlich bei
der zweiten entscheidung es wird hiermit
bundes notbremse 1 und bundes notbremse
zwei vom gericht ja selber eine
etikettierung vorgeschlagen die
ausgestaltung eines rechts auf bildung
in der konkreten form eines rechts auf
schulbildung ich habe da natürlich als
hochschullehrer gleich ein bisschen
traurig geguckt weil ich mir eigentlich
gefragt habe ob das auch ein recht auf
zugang zur hochschulbildung irgendwie
mit umfassen könnte aber
nämlich nicht kommen ebenfalls nicht
vorn aber auch nicht gefragt also das
gericht hat natürlich im grundsatz
zunächst einmal nur entschieden
was ihm vorgelegt war und hochschulen
waren in der vielzahl der
verfassungsbeschwerden dann oftmals
nicht nicht dabei und das ist in der tat
wie ich finde eine sehr begrüßenswerte
aber durchaus auch erstaunliche
weiterentwicklung des rechts also diese
eindeutige parteinahme dann letztlich
auch für die schülerinnen und schüler
ich glaube anders kann man das nicht
sagen recht auf schulische bildung aus
dem einerseits dann ganz viele wichtige
aspekte sich ableiten lassen was die
abwägung angeht darf in dieses recht
eingegriffen werden oder anders gesagt
ja vielleicht kann man sich machen mit
schulschließungen und dann zum anderen
fast noch erstaunlicher dass die
bedeutung die die schulbildung hat dann
ebenso groß ist dass das
verfassungsgericht den ländern gleich
sagen falls es dann doch mal dazu kommt
dass dieses richterrecht eingegriffen
werden muss in der pandemie aufgibt dann
jedenfalls für ersatz in gewissem sinne
zu sorgen konkret eine pflicht zum
distanz unterricht und das verdichtet
sich dann auch noch zum recht also wie
die juristen sagen zum subjektiven recht
zum anspruch auf distanz unterricht und
das ist schon sehr weit gehend
allerdings es ist auch genau das was der
bundesgesetzgeber eben bei seien
regelungen wahrscheinlich nicht konnte
weil so etwas denn ländern vorzugeben
wäre dann doch wahrscheinlich zu weit in
die kompetenz hoheit im bereich der
schule der länder gegangen aber das
verfassungsgericht kann dass er
interessant also dieses recht auf
schulische bildung hat ja auch eine ganz
interessante verankerung jetzt gefunden
in im grundgesetz das ist eine
kombination aus der freien entfaltung
der persönlichkeit nach artikel 2 absatz
1 grundgesetz in verbindung mit dem
artikel 7 absatz 1 der den
bildungsauftrag im grundgesetz
formuliert gibt es eigentlich schon
erkenntnisse darüber inwieweit das in
zukunft noch ausgestaltet werden kann
also konkret bedeutet das vielleicht
sogar dass man das schüler dann recht
haben dass es auch ordentliche
ausstattung gibt in den schulen dass die
klos funktionieren um es mal ganz
trivial zu sagen und so weiter und so
fort oder ist das noch ein bisschen zu
viel hinein interpretiert das ist
natürlich man das risiko wenn man so ein
neues recht kreiert also wenn man
rechtsprechung sät wird man
beschwerdeführer ernten in abwendung
eines demos das ja auch häufig verwendet
wird im zusammenhang mit dem
verfassungsgericht ich habe schon
zwischen den zeilen das bemühen
herausgelesen
hier einige
sicherungen einzubauen das war den
richterinnen und richtern war schon klar
dass es hier möglicherweise auch
folgeeffekte geben kann wie man in ein
derartiges recht ein anspruch das ist ja
wirklich was ganz weit reiches
postuliert und die wird sagen da ist
gleichwohl die entwicklung wie immer ein
stück weit offen daraus macht es ist
offensichtlich deswegen reden wir
darüber dass das ganze aus anlass der
pandemie und dementsprechend auch der
pandemie bezogen in seiner konkreten
begründung und in den beispielen die da
gebracht werden angelegt ist aber klar
jetzt ist es wieder verlernt es steht
sozusagen im
gesetzbuch das verfassungsrecht ist an
der stelle weiter geschrieben worden
durch das bundesverfassungsgericht und
was man daraus noch entwickeln kann wird
man sehen aber klar es ist wie
insgesamt letztlich ist es ja der
hintergrund sozialer grundrechte ein
stück weit und der machbarkeits
vorbehalt man kann das ja auch in diesem
zusammenhang einordnen soziale
grundrechte sind bei uns in der
bundesverfassung ja
eine große blüten stelle und das ist ja
eigentlich etwas wo wir mittlerweile
sowohl im innerdeutschen vergleich als
auch im europäischen vergleich mit dem
grundgesetz so ein bisschen hinterher
hinten die landesverfassung sind zum
teil deutlich weiter was soziale
grundrechte angeht mit recht auf bildung
insbesondere aber auch recht auf wohnen
und solche dinge
und in anderen verfassung europäischer
mitgliedstaaten da geht das auch sehr
viel weiter man kann aber die
europäische grundrechte charta
reinschauen und die deutsche staats
lehre waren der stelle immer sehr
konservativ und das totschlagsargument
ist letztlich immer was nutzt mir ein
grundrecht dass ich nicht einklagen kann
weil es eben keine arbeit gibt zwar es
kein wohnraum gibt
weil wir endlich die ressourcen haben um
die schulen so auszugestalten dass die
toiletten und die sonstige infrastruktur
funktioniert gut dass wir bei spielen
und toiletten aber ich denke man sieht
worauf es hinausläuft ich habe das mich
hat das nie überzeugt weil natürlich ist
ein soziales grundrecht unter diesem
realisierungs vorbehalt strukturell ein
stück weit was anderes als ein
klassisches eingriffsrecht aber das
stichwort kommt trotzdem auch bei diesem
recht auf schulische bildung dass das
auch ein abwehrrecht sein soll wenn das
jetzt in diese andere gewissem sinne
klassische bedeutung eines sozialen
grundrechts teilhabe rechts und so
weiter auch entwickelt werden kann dann
ist da in der tat noch einiges offen
aber noch mal nicht auf wir holen hier
ein stück weit auf der soziale
grundrechte sind letztlich kein
teufelszeug mehr das wird man heute auch
im grundgesetz gut gut ertragen
und wir müssen ja gar nicht so weit
gucken und gar nicht so weiterentwickeln
was das noch in zukunft für deuten
könnte man kann ja auch sehr konkret
fragen also wir haben ja jetzt die
situation dass die
voraussichtliche ampel regierung
schulschließung ganz offensichtlich
vermeiden möchte und das ja auch
explizit ausgeschlossen hat was der bund
ja auch kann weil der bund in diesem
fall die gesetzes kompetenz hat in
sachen infektionsschutz nun haben wir
sehen war aber dass einige bundesländer
also zb brandenburg jetzt
schulschließung durch die hintertür
natürlich im wesentlich kleineren ausmaß
plan also konkret die das vorziehen der
weihnachtsferien zb um ein paar tage
vielleicht werden es dann auch noch ein
zwei wochen das sollte man alles sehen
oder
auch den das aussetzen der
präsenzpflicht also im grunde oder der
schulpflicht interessanterweise also wir
grund haben ist das jetzt wieder ins
benehmen der eltern gestellt ob sie ihr
kind zur schule schicken oder nicht wird
denn das den ansprüchen dieses dieser
beschlüsse dieses beschlusses gerecht
denn da wird ja postiert also wenn ihr
schon diese einschränkung macht dann
müsst ihr auch was anderes liefern
nämlich zum beispiel distanz unterricht
oder notbetreuung
genau nun ich denke man muss als
hintergrund in der tat immer wieder
sehen dass wir hier im bereich der
konkurrierenden gesetzgebung unterwegs
sind das heißt der bund kann steuern was
die länder noch dürfen und zugleich ist
es natürlich mit dem infektionsschutz
recht das ist der kompetenz titel
letztlich hierfür die konkurrierende
gesetz geben so dass das sich
überschneiden kann mit allen möglichen
anderen zuständigkeiten hier mit
zuständigkeit für das schulwesen das bei
den ländern liegt und klar die länder
können dann möglicherweise mit den
offenen begründung argument das geht
jetzt hier und infektionsschutz mit
ihren schulen nicht mehr so umgehen wie
sie wollen aber die dinge sind natürlich
auch anders begründbar wenn aufgrund der
infektions lage einfach zu viele
lehrkräfte krank sind zum beispiel dann
kann es ja schlicht unter der unter dem
aspekt der sinnvollen aufrechterhaltung
eines schulbetriebes oder eben dass der
verunmöglichen eines weiteren
schulbetrieb ist einfach wirklich eine
frage der der schulorganisation sein
dass man eben die schulen und die
schülerinnen schüler ein stück weit
früher in die weihnachtsferien schickt
zum beispiel also da hat keine bedenken
dass das kommt immer auf den konkreten
zusammenhang an aber ich denke es liegt
auf der hand
das wie insgesamt in dieser pandemie das
schreibt manchmal ein bisschen aus dem
blick zu geraten
stichwort ende der epidemische lage
nationaler tragweite
das rächt sich nicht allzu weit von der
realität entfernen sollte und wenn die
schule neben schlicht nicht mehr
betrieben werden können weil da alle in
quarantäne und kant sind auf lehrkräfte
seite dann muss das recht das ja
irgendwie verarbeiten können
gleichzeitig glaube ich schon dass das
verfassungsgericht diese diese diese
enorme aufwertung in der position der
schülerinnen und schüler über das recht
auf schulische bildung natürlich schon
auch deswegen so deutlich artikuliert
hat dass die länder sich dass mindestens
zwei drei oder vier mal überlegen was
sie da machen weil die net hartmann hat
jetzt was in der hand ein subjektives
recht auf schulische bildung in anspruch
das kann natürlich auch eingeklagt
werden letztlich ist ja die botschaft
des verfassungsgerichts es ist auf allen
seiten
extrem hohes rechtsgut im spiel ja die
haben ja schon gesagt dass natürlich das
was gegen das recht auf schulische
bildung steht letztlich geht es hier um
leben und gesundheit
das natürlich auch wichtig und ich komme
auf meinen ausgangspunkt zurück
was das verfassungsgericht ja unter dem
strich macht ist die verantwortung für
die konkreten abwägung an die politik
zurück spielen haben mit mit einigen
fächern also kräftig nicht abstrakt für
die für die politik und sagt dir schule
ist immer wichtiger und deswegen auch
nicht auch nicht verdeckt also ich lese
das nicht so ich habe jetzt einige
kommentare wahrgenommen die behaupten ja
also mit dem urteil ist jetzt
schulschließung für unmöglich das geht
jetzt gar nicht mehr das würde ich nicht
sagen sondern das gericht sehr deutlich
das ist alles extrem
hochwertig im sinne von gewicht und wert
der in frage stehenden rechtsgüter
einerseits das was die schülerinnen und
schüler vorbringen können das recht auf
schulische bildung und zum anderen
natürlich auch das was die allgemeinheit
vorbringen kann und die abwägungen
konkreten die müssen halt die
demokratisch verantwortlichen politikern
politiker leisten kann mir vorstellen
dass was künftig nicht mehr geht es so
ein allzu freihändiger umgang mit der
schulpflicht na also man was wir zum
beispiel im letzten schuljahr gesehen
haben da hat mir in berlin die
merkwürdige konstellation dass das noch
weit also die inzidenz waren schon
längst gefallen und dann hatte der senat
noch entschieden dass wir mit zumindest
mit dem wechsel unterricht noch sehr
lange und zwar bis zu den sommerferien
weiter machen einfach weil alles andere
jetzt wie organisatorisch ein bisschen
zu schwierig sei so war die begründung
damals vom bürgermeister michael müller
und dann ist das verwaltungsgericht
reingegrätscht drei wochen vor
schulferien glaube ich und hat gesagt so
geht es nicht und ab montag bitte alle
wieder zur schule also ich glaube das
war ja immerhin schon auch ein signal
was dann vor dem
bundesverfassungsgericht
gesendet wurde aber allzu freihändig
geht's nicht mehr
aber ich würde trotzdem betonen wollen
dass man ja schon sehen muss dass die
schulbehörden dass der staat in der
konstellation natürlich auch von einer
enormen herausforderung steht weil das
ja einerseits ein massengeschäft ist das
ist ja auch teil der einordnung und
bewertung der pandemie als betrifft halt
immer unglaublich viel ändern das ja
also auch so sagen epidemiologisch
hängen daher unglaublich viele
folgeeffekte dran also schlicht die das
ganze thema ist ja letztlich kontakt
reduzierung bei der bekämpfung der
pandemie und dadurch dass man eben
schulen öffnet oder schließt hat man
hier eine stellschraube mit enorm viel
bewegen kann weil da natürlich noch die
ganzen folge bewegungen derjenigen die
schüler und schüler zu weit in die
schule bringen daran hängen und das die
ganze infrastruktur also das ist schon
ein ganz wichtiger eine ganz wichtige
stellschrauben der pandemie bekämpfung
und deswegen ist das natürlich
staatlicherseits
einerseits wichtig dass diese
stellschraube immer noch besteht und
dass hier nicht gleich sagen was
verriegelt worden ist vom
verfassungsgericht und wie sie sagen es
ist
definitiv noch schwerer als vorher wobei
ich da auch unterstellen möchte dass sie
sich auch früher die entscheidung nicht
so leicht gemacht haben es muss gut
begründet sein was man da tut vielleicht
eine sache müssen wir noch klären dann
können wir gerne zu den kontakt
beschränkungen gehen
was ja ich gesagt auch insbesondere auf
twitter
hass attacken gesagt jetzt mal sehr
schwungvoll formuliert ist dass das
bundesverfassungsgericht hier immer
davon ausging dass die schulschließung
ja auf zwei monate begrenzt gewesen sein
da meinen die aber wirklich nur die
geltung der bundes notbremse und haben
dabei also das war ja das was sie zu
begutachten haben und das war ja ein
zeitraum von 23 april bis maximal 330
juni weil die so beschränkt war und sie
haben ja zumindest im beschluss auch
deutlich gemacht weil wir reden hier
eigentlich über wesentlich mehr
tatsächlich summierte sich das auf
insgesamt 173 tage und im durchschnitt
sind die insgesamt ein halbes jahr nicht
halbe schule ja nicht zum
präsenzunterricht geladen worden
das müsste man vielleicht an dieser
stelle vielleicht auch noch mal klären
oder klar aber der der zeitliche faktor
spielt natürlich insgesamt bei der
bewertung dieser ganzen maßnahmen schon
würde das verfassungsgericht eine
wichtige rolle weil es in der tat mit
blick auf die bundeswehr von vornherein
sagen konnte das war ja in der zeit
begrenzt also da sieht man dass diese
zeitdauer durchaus von von relevanz ist
und nochmal gleichzeitig war natürlich
auch klar die bundes notbremse ist schon
ausgelaufen das liegt alles in der
vergangenheit das verfassungsgericht
macht sich nicht die arbeit der 170
seiten detailliert zu argumentieren und
irgend sowas rechts geschichtliches
nochmal zu begleiten sondern das sollte
schon auch eine aussage für das was
aktuell ansteht und was künftig
vielleicht noch kommen könnte sein
das ist vielleicht ein wichtiger ist da
würde ich gleich mal rein grätschen und
fragen
nichtsdestotrotz sieht es ja sehr aus
wie so ein blick zurück weil er eben die
besonderheit damals eben war dass wir
tatsächlich sehr viel unsicherheit
hatten auf der anderen seite auch eine
extrem niedrige impfquote jetzt ist sie
wesentlich höher noch nicht zufrieden
stellen aber wesentlich höher wir reden
davon dass 58 millionen menschen in
deutschland
vollständig geimpft sind wir haben schon
zehn millionen booster impfung und
immerhin eine impfquote von 68 wie
gesagt reicht alles nichts aus aber
ändert womöglich doch ein bisschen die
rechtslage bzw das war immer die
argumentation ich habe jedenfalls in den
beschlüssen durchaus auch diesen
schlenker auf das den impfstatus
vermisst oder deutliche hinweise darauf
oder habe ich die nur einfach nicht
wahrgenommen
ach das kommt schon mal so zwischendurch
vor der hinweis darauf dass jedenfalls
zum gegenwärtigen zeitpunkt die
impfkampagne noch nicht so weit war dass
die da eine sozusagen einen sicheren
parameter abgegeben hätte aber ich
wundere mich trotzdem ein bisschen über
die diskussion wie sie jetzt zum teil
glaube beobachtet zu haben
die darauf hinausläuft zu sagen wir sind
jetzt in einer ganz anderen situation
weil jetzt haben wir den impfstoff und
ganz viele sind doch schon geimpft das
verfassungsgericht macht ja an
verschiedenen stellen sehr deutlich dass
das zentrale problem ja die unterbindung
der virus übertragung ist und da muss
man schlicht danach fragen wie weit sind
wir damit also und wir wissen dass auch
geimpfte den virus über teilt das virus
übertragen können wir haben zudem eben
auch noch nicht hinreichend viele mit
alliance kampagne erreicht dass hier bei
der virus übertragung sich effekte
einstellen die vielleicht substanziell
eine andere bewertung zu lassen klar ist
dass das eine rolle spielt also wenn
beispiel eben das virus so mutiert dass
es noch besser und effektiver dann durch
eine impfung dazu kommt dass eben gar
keine virus übertragung der stattfindet
wäre das natürlich eine ganz andere
tatsachengrundlage aber das sehe ich
zurzeit nicht und wo da noch große
unsicherheiten sind sagt das
verfassungsgericht ja auch sehr deutlich
dann kann der staat im zweifel eben die
sachverständigen die die die
fachwissenschaftliche auffassung die
diese
möglichkeiten und potenziale täten
artikuliert zur grundlage seiner
entscheidung machen aber was bringt denn
das impfen dann naja also jetzt
epidemiologisch oder rechtlich
beides also epidemiologisch vielleicht
um das noch einmal deutlich zu machen
sie haben es ja gesagt also es gibt
natürlich
verhindert nicht die übertragung also
ist vermindert sie sagen wir mal so es
verhindert sie aber nicht und wir
schützen uns natürlich vor schweren
erkrankungen das ist völlig unbenommen
aber wenn es nicht so eindeutig ist
epidemiologisch dass wir sagen können
hier wird einfach auch die virus
übertragung gestoppt was kann sich dann
für rechtliche konsequenzen anschließen
ich so wie ich sie jetzt verstehe
ehrlich gesagt sagen sie dass die
impfung jetzt eigentlich nicht besonders
rechtlich nicht besonders für
unterschied macht zum gegenwärtigen
zeitpunkt also wir sind jetzt ende
november anfang dezember 20 21 und da
haben wir knapp 15 millionen erwachsene
die noch nicht geimpft sind und da würde
man wenn ich recht sehe ist das ja auch
der hintergrund der impfpflicht
diskussion sagen das reicht eben noch
nicht um die epidemiologischen effekte
die wir in anderen ländern ja durchaus
beobachten
verzeichnen zu können die es daneben
auch erlauben auf der rechtlichen ebene
schlussfolgerung zu ziehen in richtung
dann müssen bestimmte maßnahmen auch
milder ausfallen also nochmal wenn das
zentrale anliegen all dieser maßnahmen
ist die virus übertragung möglichst zu
reduzieren
dann kann man das natürlich einerseits
dadurch erreichen dass man diese
maßnahmen ergreift ja dass man sagen
hier bleibt jetzt alle mal zu hause oder
wenn wir halt wissen gifte übertragen
das virus weniger häufig haben weniger
virus lässt
dann ist natürlich auch die impfkampagne
und der umstand dass viele geimpft sind
ein aspekt in der abwägung es ist ja
alles abwägung und letztlich läuft ja
auch in den beiden beschlüssen alles auf
eine verhältnismäßigkeitsprüfung hinaus
die aber an letztlich allen
prüfstationen der verhältnismäßigkeit
die juristen unterscheiden da ja sehr
kleinteilig zwischen der geeignetheit
erforderlichkeit und dann nochmal der
angemessenheit
in zweckel relationen letztlich eben und
an all diesen stellen wird in den
beschlüssen vom verfassungsgericht eben
sehr deutlich gemacht interessanterweise
gibt es auch rechts vergleichen
unterfüttert dass es sich auf eine
vertretbarkeit prüfung zurückzieht ja
also umsonst wer konnte man das konnte
man das so machen oder gibt es eben
evidenter maßen argumente die diese
argumentation des staates nicht zulassen
das ist letztlich ein offenkundigkeit
argument und in diesen
bewertungen abwägungen spielt er
natürlich in der tat dass tatsächlich
eine rolle und wenn durch die
impfkampagne höhere wirksamkeit des
impfstoffs oder einfach verbreitet aber
anzahl von geimpften insgesamt dann die
übertragung die virus übertrage
eingedämmt ist dann hat das natürlich
auch folgen für das was sie an sonstigen
maßnahmen anschließen darf das ist alles
insgesamt zu sagen und das ziel quasi
die intensivstation frei zu halten also
das wäre ja auch oder ist es ja auch
etwas was immer wieder gebetsmühlenartig
vorgetragen wird das dass das
eigentliche ziel wird und das ist ja
schon jetzt durch jede individuelle
impfentscheidung durchaus war ja wird
befördert weil wir immer wieder hören
dass die geimpften nicht auf den oder
weniger waren wir so auf den
intensivstationen landen genau also es
scheint doch einigermaßen gesichert so
sein dass der stand der medizinischen
erkenntnisse in dem kontext dass die
impfung jedenfalls vor schweren
krankheitsverläufen doch überwiegend
schützt und schwere krankheitsverläufe
sind hat diejenigen die die
intensivstation dann auch belasten zum
nachteil aller also nach dann auch all
derjenigen also auch zum nachteil der
geimpften die sich eben aus anderen
gründen in eine intensivmedizinische
behandlung begeben müssten und dann da
keinen freien platz mehr finden weil da
irgendwelche ungeimpften sind dies
möglicherweise auch noch selbst so
entschieden haben die dann aber sehr
schwer krank geworden sind was eben
wahrscheinlicher ist soviel kann man
schon sagen wenn man nicht geimpft ist
ja nicht jemand zu sein macht es
wahrscheinlicher dass man schwer
erkrankt kommen wir jetzt mal zu den
kontakt beschränkungen das ist ja
insofern auch wirklich ganz spannend
gewesen als er die ausgangssperren auch
immer etwas waren was sehr umstritten
war was insbesondere von der fdp ja
konkret auch angegangen wurde da waren
ja auch 80 abgeordnete die tatsächlich
dagegen geklagt haben die mit einer
verfassungsbeschwerde vor dem
bundesverfassungsgericht gezogen sind
die argumentation war immer dass die
ausgangs beschränkung ja selber kaum
auswirkungen hat sondern im grunde
genommen nur flankieren soll die kontakt
beschränkungen die ansonsten relativ
schwer zu kontrollieren ist natürlich
einfacher jemanden quasi auf der straße
abzufangen wenn er zu einer party möchte
zu einer illegalen corona party möchte
als tatsächlich diese partie selber
hochgehen zu lassen kann man sich ja in
der tat auch vorstellen
das hat jetzt das
bundesverfassungsgericht aber abgesegnet
da würde ich auch so sehen und mir hat
das auch immer eingeleuchtet wir sind ja
hier einem massengeschäft das kann man
natürlich im konkreten einzelfall
glasperlenspiel artig argumentieren
dieser oder jener fall da wäre es doch
wesentlich weniger einschneidend wenn
man das eben ohne so eine ausgangssperre
sicherstellen dass er die kontakte
minimiert werden aber allein in den
großstädten wenn sich das vorstellen wie
man das nicht wie man das umsetzen
wollte mir hat das schon eingeleuchtet
dass man hier um es effektiv zu machen
und die effektivität
ist er letztlich dass gerade in der
pandemie noch mehr als sonst in
rechtlichen zusammenhängen wirklich dann
auch fast schon überlebensnotwendiger es
geht hier um fragen von leben und tod
letztlich und da muss es funktionieren
und da hat mir das schon sehr
eingeleuchtet zu sagen dann müssen wir
im zweifel auch wenn das dann in der
konkreten anwendung auch mal nicht so
richtig hinhaut müssen wir können wir
das sollten wir das über diese
ausgangssperren machen können also
stichwort der einsiedler die
einsiedlerin die da irgendwo weit ab
wohnt und wo man sagt ja jetzt dann noch
mal abends vor die tür tritt 20
kilometer keine menschenseele im umkreis
das kann er jetzt die pandemie nicht
befördert ja klar man kann immer solche
lehrbuch beispiele möchte ich fast sagen
bringen aber man muss immer gleichzeitig
im blick behalten das muss ja hier
funktionieren das muss hier
funktionieren in einem 80 millionen land
und das hat das bundesverfassungsgericht
wie ich glaube hier auch sehr deutlich
gesehen und noch mal wie insgesamt den
beschlüssen hat sich die entscheidung
überhaupt nicht leicht gemacht hat sehr
deutlich darauf verwiesen dass es ihrem
schwerste eingriffe geht und hat in dem
beschluss der jetzt unter anderem auch
die ausgangssperren betrifft so ganz am
schluss noch mal gesagt so als hätten
sie es am schluss noch mal festhalten
wollen für den hastigen leser der nur
den anfang und den schluss von beschluss
liest ja umfassende ausgangs
beschränkungen nur in äußerste
gefahrenlage es kommt noch mal so so
hinterher so drang geklatscht fast an
die entscheidung also die wollten das
schon sehr deutlich artikulieren dass
sie das extrem ernst nehmen und
gleichzeitig haben wir das sehr sehr
detailliert und clyde kleinteilig wie
ich meine geprüft und nachgewiesen dass
es in dieser situation die sie zu
bewerten hatten mit der verfassung
vereinbar ist und ich finde an einer
stelle geben sie einen hinweis darauf es
könnte auch noch ganz anders kommen als
sie nämlich sagen dass das ja auch
sachverständige gab das wird gleichsam
noch so mitgeteilt die mit blick auf
erfahrungen in großbritannien portugal
sogar ganztägige ausgangssperren
empfohlen haben bei den rede standen
hier ja überwiegend auch diese
nächtlichen drei zeitlich begrenzten
ausgangssperren also das
verfassungsgericht hält mal kurz
sozusagen den auch möglichen
argumentation stand der
wissenschaftlichen erkenntnis hoch dass
man vielleicht sogar mit mit noch
umfassenderen ausgangssperren hier hier
auch hätte kommen können also das sehe
ich auch in der entscheidung
kommt denn jetzt eigentlich noch mehr
also wir haben erinnert hat noch nicht
alles abgeräumt gibt es noch spannender
fragen die geklärt werden müssen die
jetzt noch anstehen warten sie noch auf
irgendwas oder sagen sie ja jetzt haben
sehen wir eigentlich klarer und jetzt
konzentrieren wir uns mal wieder auf die
gesetzgebung
sie wollen beim bundesverfassungsgericht
oder inseln bei der rechtsprechung
wie beim bundesverfassungsgericht das
waren ja über 300 verfassungsbeschwerden
die da
anhängig war naja ich glaube es gibt
noch höhere zahlen ich habe auch aus
1800 verfassungsbeschwerden was mit der
größten können das ist hat sicher viele
gegeben die sich hier noch mal zur wehr
gesetzt haben und da ist ja noch das ein
oder anderen der pipeline aber
die die macher dieser beiden beschlüsse
sind lässt schon sehr deutlich erkennen
dass es hier um
grundsatzentscheidungen geht die
letztlich dann eben auch die
rechtsprechung in dem bereich natürlich
anleiten werden und zwar dann auch die
eigene rechtsprechung also alles was da
noch anhängig ist wird im zweifel so
weit es sich auf solche maßnahmen
bezieht dadurch angeleitet werden aber
klar die die bundes notbremse war ja nur
ein pfeil im köcher der pandemie
bekämpfung letztes jahr sie ist
ausgelaufen sie war ja der seltene fall
dass der bund selber mal geregelt hat es
ist ja eigentlich vergleich mit
österreich wo wir das jetzt auch gerade
beobachten stichwort einführung der
impfpflicht und was er sonst noch
passiert auch denkbar dass der bund das
ganze an sich nimmt konkurrierende
gesetzgebung könnte er müsste mal als
infektionsschutzgesetz entsprechend
ändern das ist ja möglicherweise
durchaus absichtsvoll könnte man fast
überlegen so dass es eigentlich für die
bundesebene ganz angenehm ist dass die
harten entscheidungen letztlich auf der
länder ebene
getroffen oder jedenfalls verantwortet
werden müssen aber der bund kann dass
der bund könnte das komplett an sich
ziehen und den infektionsschutz hier
noch sehr viel dichter selbst regeln und
entsprechend die verwaltung
vorprogrammieren hat er nicht gemacht
außer bundes notbremse und wie ich finde
auch interessant vielleicht auch gerade
so sehr technischer rechtlicher punkt
aber die juristen finden das problem
sicher ganz faszinierend die ganze
regelungstechnik gibt es vom
verfassungsgericht ja auch für
verfassungskonform erklärt worden haben
ja so eine solche automatik hat nur ab
sondern bestimmten incidents greifen
bestimmte rechtsfolgen und das ist
natürlich nicht so wie man sich sonst
staatliches handeln
vorstellt dass da der gesetzgeber
programmiert und dann wird es durch die
exekutive ausgeführt und dann habe ich
gegen diese konkrete ausführung
natürlich meine
rechtsschutzmöglichkeiten das feld dann
plötzlich alles weg und es droht der
möglicherweise eben auch ein
rechtsschutz defizit hat das
verfassungsgericht aber alles
thematisiert und hat gesagt immer auch
unter dem aspekt
besondere situation aufgrund der
hochwertigen rechtsgüter die hier in
rede stehen leben und gesundheit da
durfte der gesetzgeber ebenso regeln
also noch mal was können wir aus was was
gibt die entscheidung ist mit jetzt für
für die zukunft möglicherweise also der
bund
könnte auch mit dieser regelungstechnik
weiter unterwegs sein wenn die umstände
das entsprechend begründen und ansonsten
sind natürlich gegen die konkreten
maßnahmen die sich jetzt nicht aus der
bundesrat sperrt bundes notbremse des
letzten jahres ergeben sondern aus dem
sozusagen regel motto ist der pandemie
bekämpfung wo die länder unterwegs sind
mit ihren handlungs form da sind sicher
auch noch verfahren beim
verfassungsgericht unterwegs aber so wie
die entscheidung formuliert sind denke
ich schon dass das allermeiste aus den
bundes notbremse entscheidungen da eben
auch vorgibt wie dann mit einer maßnahme
konkret maßnahmen im land zu verfahren
ist ganz zum schluss möchte ich noch an
natürlich eine frage stellen weil wir ja
inzwischen jetzt eine neue situation
haben also der designierte bundeskanzler
olaf scholz hat ja doch vehement oder
sehr deutlich jetzt eine allgemeine
impfpflicht ins spiel gebracht wurde
auch sehr konkret mit der maßgabe dass
der bundestag das bis ende februar
beschließen soll der fraktionszwang wird
aufgehoben
verfassungsrechtliche bedenken spielten
da ja auch immer eine rolle wie würden
sie das sehen
also diese impfpflicht thematik ist in
der tat jetzt in der jugendzeit ja auch
so als verfassungsrechtliches thema
intensiv diskutiert worden wobei mir so
die grundsätzliche frage sozusagen die
frage des ob nicht wirklich als
verfassungsrechtliches problem vorkommen
dass es gibt der 22 artikel 2 absatz 2
grundgesetz ja eindeutig her dass die
körperliche unversehrtheit und die wir
zentral gehen durch gesetze
eingeschränkt werden kann natürlich kann
man auch andere grundrechte heranziehen
da geht es dann um eltern recht zum
beispiel oder vielleicht auch
religionsausübung das ist in den usa im
kontext der m5 zum beispiel ganz
zentrales thema gewesen aber an sich
scheint mir dass ob der möglichkeit ja
es geht ja um die möglichkeit man kann
ja dann politisch immer noch anders
entscheiden
der möglichkeit einer einführung einer
impfpflicht recht offensichtlich und das
fertig ich sehe wirklich kaum jemanden
der das bestreitet unter den
verfassungsrechtler im verfassungsrecht
dann also geht es zentral um das wie und
da sehe ich schon das ein oder andere in
den entscheidungen
was hier hilfreich sein kann da geht es
bei dieser eine stelle in der
bundesliga 1 gesagt wird bei der prüfung
der eignung einer maßnahme ja das
eignung die geeignetheit einer maßnahme
nicht voraussetzt dass zweifelsfreie
empirische nachweise der wirkung der
wirksamkeit bestehen da gibt es also
auch prognose spielräume für den
gesetzgeber oder auch dass mit den
milderen mittel gibt ja jetzt leute die
argumentieren ja also wir müssen also
auch für eine impfpflicht erst mal
vorher noch alles wirklich jeden impf
unbedingt auch mal höchst persönlich
gebeten haben ob er sehe nicht
vielleicht doch bitte bitte bereit wäre
sich impfen zu lassen also da sehe ich
im in den beschlüssen auch die die
hinweise die sehr deutlich
hergeben das dass man hier als
gesetzgeber sehr wohl
zum beispiel auf die impfpflicht besorge
bezogen sagen könnte es gab ein
freiwilliges angebot und der impfstoffe
auch lange verfügbar und dass das war
dann das mittels mittel spielen den impf
durchbrüche da eine rolle in dem sinne
dass dann ja das sagen der impfgegner
dann in diesem zusammenhang oder
jedenfalls leute die diesen dieser
maßnahme skeptisch gegenüberstehen die
sagen naja aber wir sehen ja auch dass
eine impfung nicht vollständig schützt
oder fällt das in diesen rahmen den sie
gerade genannt haben vom prognose
spielraum und der tatsache dass nicht
alles hinreichend wissenschaftlich
fundiert geklärt werden muss
beziehungsweise wenn eben die
wissenschaftlichen erkenntnisse an der
stelle noch unvollständig sind und
volatil sind dann kann der gesetzgeber
durchaus entscheiden
das dass man es trotzdem versucht ja
also diese spielräume sind auf jeden
fall da und nochmal es kommt dann
natürlich auch wieder auf die begründung
an also was ist das ziel einer
impfpflicht ist es die pandemie
bekämpfung im sinne von dadurch dass wir
dann viele geimpfte haben werden
vorrangig daneben auch wird die virus
übertragen minimiert ist es dann
weitergehen das ziel dass man die
überlastung der intensivstation und
damit eben zusammenbruch der
gesundheitsversorgung für alle versucht
zu minimieren und das sind ja auch alles
extrem hochrangige rechtsgüter die da in
den blick kommen da geht es ja auch um
leben und gesundheit von ganz vielen und
da nochmal entnehme ich der art und
weise wie das verfassungsgericht im
bundes notbremse 1 und 2 uns die
abwägung ford und doch erhebliche
spielräume und ein großes verständnis
letztlich auch für diejenigen die die
entscheidungen treffen müssen das sollte
man vielleicht auch noch mal sagen
eigentlich sind diese beiden
entscheidungen bundes notbremse 1 bundes
notbremse zwei sind ja auch ein enormer
erfolg für diejenigen die das alles
verantwortet haben ja es wird ihnen
nicht wie ist ja sonst oft vorkommt vom
verfassungsgericht noch mal gesagt ihr
dumm beutel was habt ihr da wieder
gemacht dass mit etwas so oder so machen
müssen sondern ich lese aus dieser aus
diesen beiden entscheidungen schon ein
hohes maß an respekt gegenüber
denen die diese entscheidungen
verantworten mussten jetzt bundes
notbremse konkret heraus und diese
ernsthaftigkeit die überträgt sich
sicherlich dann auch auf alles was eine
mögliche impfpflicht angeht
also auch da wird man grundsätzlich von
seiten des verfassungsgerichts
unterstellen
dass man mir vonseiten des staates hier
nicht anders konnte und dass man
wirklich eben auch
hochrangige rechtsgüter hier versucht zu
schützen und das honoriert das
verfassungsgericht bei der
entsprechenden begründung aber die
begründung das finde ich daneben auch
durchaus
deutlich in den beiden beschlüssen die
begründungen die müssen die müssen schon
gut sein ja aber das kriegt man ihnen
denke ich vor allem wenn man sich jetzt
noch die zeit nehmen will bis februar
oder märz da jetzt ist nichts und
schnellschuss sein wie sonst in der
pandemie das ist ja vielleicht auch so
eine beobachtung die wir jetzt
eigentlich über die letzten anderthalb
jahre machen mussten dass es nicht
gelungen ist die maßgeblichen gesetze
mal so im regel modus zu ändern richtig
auch mal ausgeruht ja was eigentlich
hätte hätte passieren können also gerade
jetzt
fragt man sich ja im rückblick schon
warum hat man nicht schon im sommer
vorausschauender überlegt wie es
weitergehen könnte wie mir überhaupt in
der ganzen pandemie verarbeitung so ein
bisschen dieses vorausschauende planung
fehlt
aber da kann ich ihnen dank das war
unser pech dass wir gerade in diesem
jahr im wahlkampf waren so ist das
leider herzlichen dank herr professor
meyer für diesen doch sehr integrierten
ritt durch die bundes notbremse 1 und
bundes notbremse zwei ja keinen spaß
gemacht vielen dank
so jetzt haben wir eine sehr umfassende
analyse zu den beschlüssen gestern des
bundesverfassungsgerichts gehört und
kommen jetzt nun zu einem jahr ganz
anderen thema nehme ich das deutsche
telekom mammut verfahren erzähl doch mal
markus worum geht es da ja ich könnte
diese direkt mitten in einer frage
zurück gehen sagen dir die tatort
kommissare manfred krug und charles
brauer noch was ja na klar als manfred
krug war ja auch so
eine eine prägende figur des deutschen
fernsehens möchten genau für die etwas
jüngeren zuhörer dieses podcast das
waren nicht nur zwei sehr bekannte
schauspieler anja mittlerweile schon
seit ein paar jahren verstorbenen
manfred krug sondern auch zwei der
begnadete sänger haben also auch bei
jeder gelegenheit immer liedgut und
musik zum besten gegeben und waren aber
auch in diesem zeitraum ende der 90er
jahre anfang der nullerjahre sehr
gefragte testimonials beziehungsweise
werbeträger für deutsche unternehmen und
damit natürlich ideal für eine kampagne
wenn du ein produkt an den markt bringen
will oder in dem fall eine kapitalanlage
an den markt bringen willst mit jemanden
der einen hohen wiedererkennungswert hat
dann war das natürlich ein perfect fit
in dem zusammenhang und zwar geht es
darum dass der immer noch sehr stars
telekom konzern aus bonn ab ende der
90er jahre in diversen börsengang aktien
unters volk gebracht hat die dann auch
ich habe ein bisschen vorweg gegriffen
schon den etwas bezeichnen haben
volksaktie bekommen haben das war die
sogar je aktie man wollte tatsächlich
auch die deutschen in die geld in die
kapitalanlage die aktienanlage locken
einfach da schon erklärtes ziel nehmen
wir sollten alle ein bisschen aktiver
sein und die die deutsche telekom war da
ein vehikel aber das ganze ist ja
ordentlich schief gegangen genau wir
haben interessanterweise auch wenn da
jetzt fast zwei jahrzehnte dazwischen
liegen etwas vergleichbare situation
auch jetzt die
inflation ist ja relativ hoch die
menschen suchen anlagemöglichkeiten
immer mehr leute investieren am markt
und so war das tatsächlich auch ende der
90er anfang der nullerjahre in
sogenannten und neuem markt da hatte
sich die telekom als bislang etwas
träger player am kapitalmarkt natürlich
auch versucht zu positionieren und hat
natürlich auch mit dem altbekannten
namen es fanden sich immer sichere
anlage ist ein bekannter name aber
gleichzeitig war man ja auch sehr
expansiv unterwegs hat dann auch neue
märkte in europa oder auch gerade in
nordamerika sich erschlossen
versucht das natürlich auch zu nutzen
diesem momentum um neue anteilseigener
strich privatanleger zu ködern nichts
und dann ist vielleicht so negativ
gesagt aber natürlich für sich zu
gewinnen und das war eben durch die
besagten kampagnen mit manfred krug und
charles brauer nach anderen sehr stark
geprägt so das war im grunde nahm dann
auch eine sehr sehr große enttäuschung
relativ schnell weil da der aktienkurs
sich nicht so entwickelt hat genau sich
das viele vorstellen aber sag doch mal
was ist wo wird es rechtlich relevant
war genau landete das dann tatsächlich
vor den gerichten in deutschland die der
dritte börsengang war im jahr 2000 im
frühsommer mit dem ausgabepreis der auf
euro umgerechnet bei etwas mehr als 66
euro lag damals also in dem zeitraum
haben vor allen dingen viele leute kurz
vor dem renteneinstieg bei diesen aktien
zugegriffen das weiß man mittlerweile
und die party an der börse über die sich
viel gefreut haben war relativ schnell
vorbei denn der aktienkurs der deutschen
telekom ist nach unten haben die leute
also sehr hohe verluste gemacht wie es
dann natürlich auch so ist hohe
kursverluste macht man in deutschland im
regelfall wenn dann auch jemand
natürlich wie ein anleger anwälte oder
verbraucher anwälte dann nochmal genau
und kritisch drauf gucken möglicherweise
auch ansprüche geltend dass es dann auch
hier passiert man hat versucht über das
so genannte konstrukt um der prospekt
haftungsklage der deutschen telekom
einen prospekt haftungs fehler im
verkaufsprospekt mal vorzuhalten diesen
verkaufsprospekten muss jeder emittent
eine aktie vorlegen da sind die
wichtigsten informationen dringelegen
und da wurde der deutschen telekom
vorgehalten wurden im zusammenhang mit
transaktionen geschäftsbeziehungen in
nordamerika
bezugnahme auf ein anderes unternehmen
das ist die sprinter
unregelmäßigkeiten stattgefunden haben
sollen da geht es also der transaktion
auch in milliarden-höhe die nicht
richtig dargestellt worden sein sollen
und daraufhin fanden dann ab dem
frühjahr 2001 als knapp ein dreiviertel
jahr schon nach diesem börsengang die
ersten klagen angst einzug gegen die
deutsche telekom aber auch gegen den
bund und die kfw und diverse andere
banken darunter auch commerzbank und
deutsche bank als konsortialbanken
diesem diesen der börsengang begleitet
haben und das hat man in deutschland so
in der fülle dann erstmal nicht gekannt
denn ab 2001 bis in das die nächsten
jahre danach 24 gab es einfach dann
fülle an klagen die vor allen dingen das
landgericht in frankfurt betroffen haben
wohl auch die deutsche börse und auch
der meiste börsenhandel in deutschland
stattfindet und daraufhin hat man in
berlin sich gedanken gemacht wie man
denn möglicherweise so eine fülle
einzelner klagen die alle relativ
ähnlich gelagert sind in deutschland
irgendwie strukturieren könnte denn wir
erinnern uns bis heute gibt es ja in dem
sinne keine sammelklage so wie er sich
nach amerikanischen vorbild in
deutschland kennen und dann hat der
gesetzgeber im jahr 25 das sogenannte
jetzt kommt ein sehr komplexes wort ich
werde es aber klar ich dann nur noch mit
einer abkürzung benutzen dass
kapitalanleger verfahren
musterverfahrensgesetz ins leben gerufen
und wir juristen sprechen in dem
zusammenhang eigentlich nur vom kapmug
das ist die abkürzung aber es wird immer
wieder auch im kontext von sogenannten
lex telekom gesprochen weil es einfach
ein gesetz ist das sehr stark mit diesem
verfahren über das wetter reden
verknüpft ist genau und da haben wir im
grunde genommen zwei probleme die sich
in diesem verfahren deutlich zeigen zum
einen ist ja ehrlich gesagt schon der
anspruch ein bisschen schwierig nach
also tatsächlich kings den anlegern
darum dass sie wahnsinnige verluste
gemacht haben und tatsächlich den fehler
natürlich auch bei der bei der telekom
suchten da muss man dann eben über das
vehikel der prospekthaftung gehen und
sagen wir wohnen nicht über die risiken
hinreichend aufgeklärt das war punkt 1.2
daneben die dramatik oder die
schwierigkeit dass man es hier mit mit
tausenden von verfahren zu drohen hatte
die alle irgendwie gleich gelagert waren
und die man irgendwie bündeln mussten
das hat man dann eben versucht über das
kapmug zu leading man kann vielleicht
schon vorwegnehmen das ergebnis und
sagen das ist nicht so ganz gelungen
waren man sieht dass das ganze er
immerhin noch also 20 jahre andauerte
und jetzt vielleicht das ende in sicht
ist aber noch nicht ganz greifbar noch
nicht ganz kraft also der sinn und zweck
dieses cups ist dass man sich
gewissermaßen einen musterkläger heraus
greift das muss jetzt nicht mehr
unbedingt derjenige sein der die meisten
aktien gekauft hat aber man hat damals
schon versucht zu schauen auch eine
situation die größten das vergleichbar
ist mit anderen fällen da hat man sich
dann einen mittlerweile verstorbenen
muss man auch sagen das ist ja auch die
trage diese zusammen ein komplexes rennt
man baden württemberg rausgesucht und
der kläger hat das ding nicht überlebte
also das neue hat so lange gedauert der
iss früher gestorben als er da sitzt
gewissermaßen die erbengemeinschaft des
klägers neben dem klägervertreter dass
die kanzlei tilp in dem fall wieder sehr
bekannt ist aber wie sie es sagen das
war ja auch ein großer fan von die
telekom den gesamten 15 jahren die nun
dieser musterverfahrens prozess jetzt
schon läuft an die telekom dass sie die
sache gewissermaßen aus sicht einer der
stärksten vorwürfe in richtung viele
kommen datiert aus dem jahr 2016 als der
andreas typ der damalige klägervertreter
ganz klar gesagt hat sie warten ja auch
eine biologische lösung
mit anderen worten er hat den
vorgeworfen der telekom dass sie das
aussitzen und warten bis die kläger alle
versterben und die haben sich noch nicht
einig sind wie es mit dem sachen
weitergeht aber dazu muss man ja auch
fairerweise sagen das ganze hat ja nun
verschiedene runden gedreht vielleicht
gehen wir mal darauf ein also es hat
zunächst alles begonnen in frankfurt in
frankfurt
das telekom verfahren sieht dann so vor
dass der eine musterkläger ein
vorlagebeschluss formuliert er muss da
noch abgesegnet werden vom landgericht
beziehungsweise oberlandesgericht das
ganze verfahren läuft dann an einem
spezial senat am oberlandesgericht und
diese spezial senats am
oberlandesgericht hat jetzt dieses
verfahren in der vergangenen woche ist
zum insgesamt dritten mal auf dem tisch
gehabt das ist schonmal paradoxon weil
wie du eben schon angedeutet hat die
sache lag mittlerweile zweimal ein
casino bundesgerichtshof um die
dimension noch mal kurz darzustellen
dann konnten sich alle anderen kläger
die im ersten fall in erster instanz am
landgericht schon geklagt haben wenn sie
wollten diesen verfahren anschließen das
haben sehr sehr viele getan insgesamt
geht man von bis zu 17.000 einzelkläger
hinaus die unmittelbar von diesem muster
klage dann auch profitieren werden
können und die volumen ihre forderung
die gehen ein bisschen auseinander wenn
man dem telekom geschäftsberichten den
risiko berichten glauben darf dann sind
das ungefähr 80 millionen euro bekommen
aber da wahrscheinlich noch so genannte
prozesszinsen drauf die man auch darauf
rechnen musste die kläger gruppen da
reden wir über alleine 600 einzel
kanzlei in deutschland die da
verschiedene kläger betreut haben die
haben dann irgendwann versucht das
zusammenzufassen und geben also die
forderung mit einer summe von bis zu 200
millionen aus das klingt für jetzige und
heutiger chance satz prozess wohl ganz
anderen summen natürlich zu tun haben
erst mal wenig aber das paar damals
einfach riesig vergleich mit diese zb
nicht sicher auf milliarden genau wie du
schon gesagt hast dass der prozess geht
also ab 26 läuft er in gange
aber die vorbereitung heute unheimlich
viel zeit in anspruch genommen bis man
dann tatsächlich zum ersten mal wirklich
verhandelt hat hin und her sich
ausgetauscht hat man musste auch weil
man ja gedacht hat da kommen eventuell
tausende von menschen die betroffen sind
sie sich das anhören wollen hat man in
frankfurt eine der größten hallen dies
gibt das ist nicht mein fall jetzt nicht
die vielen bekannte messehalle die man
irgendwie leicht aus konzerten können
sondern ein saalbau in den an in einem
fort aber ich war selbst als redakteur
damals vor ort um diese erwartung war
ein bisschen enttäuscht wurden
enttäuscht weil dann einfach in diesem
riesigen zahl doch sehr wenige menschen
auch bedingt durch durch den
wintereinbruch damals im jahr 2 84 28
nicht da war
es war ein bisschen grotesk mehr es war
aber tatsächlich so ist waren wahnsinnig
viele anwälte da gab ja da also die
deutsche telekom ist mit ordentlich
leuten aufgetreten dann gab es natürlich
prozessvertreter es gab aber auch
anwälte die sich das einfach angehört
haben für ihre felle und
es wurden vor allen dingen im vorfeld
also wirklich lastwagen von dokumenten
schlimm da ausgekippt wir reden ja wir
reden ja über ein verfahren das größeren
weil man so sagen doch aus der analogen
zeit noch überhaupt in die digitale es
gibt wahnsinnige viele pressebilder auch
im relativen wirklich
aktenberg oder diese akten bürger diesen
der justiz geübt mit voll mit akten zu
diesem telekom musterverfahren sieht der
die erste runde lief so weit ich das ein
rekapitulieren kann von 2008 bis 2011 12
dann ging es zum ersten mal zum bgh der
bgh hat dann im jahr 2012 entschieden
und das nochmal zurück verwiesen
wiederum ans olg für eine weitere runde
da hat es dann in der zweiten auflage
wir um fast vier jahre gebraucht bis zum
oktober 2016 über den fall habe ich
damals auch schon für die faz berichtet
da kamen auch diese aussage von herrn
zurück die ich eben schon erwähnt hat
und damals hat man in frankfurt gesagt
ja wir sehen da möglicherweise
den prospekt fehler und wohin lag dieser
dieser vielen mann hat in nordamerika in
der transaktion eine umhängen von aktien
oder von von anteilen gegenüber dieses
bündnis sie falsch deklariert so
detailliert ehrlich gesagt war es dann
die argumentation genau und da hat man
aber dann gesehen da ich sehen wir den
prospekt fehler und dann gehts ja
natürlich immer juristisch weiter
liegt ein verschulden vor oder nicht
ohne der dritten stufe wird es halt
immer eine frage die auch dann auch
jetzt am ende noch einmal eine große
rolle gespielt hat ist denn dieser
konkrete fehler mit dem verschulden
dafür abhängig oder wirklich bedingt der
die kaufentscheidung 20 jahre vorher und
da kann man ehrlicherweise sagen
wahrscheinlich in 99 prozent der fälle
nein und ja weil wir im frühjahr dann
wieder um den beschluss mittlerweile
sind zwei mal aus karlsruhe gesehen
haben indem er das bejaht hat aber diese
frage der sogenannten haftungs
ausführenden kausalität noch mal auf den
tisch gebracht hat die hätte dann in der
neuen konstellation jetzt in frankfurt
rolle spielen müssen und hätten wir dann
zu dieser etwas chaotischen situation
gekommen dass die telekom sich zwar
durchsetzen konnte mit ihrer forderung
ja wir wollten eigentlich gerne über
einen sachverständigen klären lassen was
war denn damals ende der 90er anfang
jahr 2000 also das klima was hat die
leute dafür bewegt dass die t aktie
kaufen nur gab es dann stichwort
darlegungs und beweislast mittlerweile
die situation dass die telekom mit einem
sachverständigen und bis zu 17.000
einzelklagen den leuten hätte nachweisen
müssen was denn ihre motivation vor 20
jahren gewesen ist und jetzt frage ich
dich grüner kannst du dich daran
erinnern was deine motivation in
einzelnen geldanlagen vor 20 jahren
gewesen ist ich bezweifle ich will da
nichts unterstellen aber ich stelle es
aber sehr schwer vor ehrlich gesagt also
das ist ja dieses dilemma vor dem man
wahrscheinlich steht das ist er auch
eine interessante frage letztendlich als
natur ich haben sich die leute die da
die kleinanleger jetzt den prospekt
wahrscheinlich der werden den ich
auswendig gelernt haben nun insbesondere
die
beteiligung wird da nicht besonders ins
auge gesprungen sein allerdings gibt es
ja nun bestimmte anforderungen an an an
so einen prospekt der die auch erfüllt
werden müssen sonst könnte man ja da
reinschreiben was man wollte ja und im
grunde genommen ist ja dann
wahrscheinlich die der grundsatz dass
man sich als anleger eine sichere
investition wünscht ja die jedenfalls
natürlich sich in die eine oder andere
richtung entwickeln kann aber man möchte
natürlich
ausschließen dass es da schon faule eier
im korb sozusagen gab die man nicht
erkennt ja und dafür soll sozusagen das
ist quasi sinn und zweck dieser
prospekthaftung
dem den kleiner liga da nicht über
gebühr bei den tisch zieht indem man ihn
gefahren und risiken und aus der
position der telekom war es einfach so
dass über die jahre immer wieder gesagt
hat und dann auch zurückgewichen ist in
ihrer position zuerst dem prospekt
fehler nicht anerkannt hat dann war das
thema verschulden da und wir jetzt
natürlich dann in der situation waren
dass der bgh schon eine sehr deutliche
position dargestellt hat aber noch eine
option auf dem tisch legte mit diesem
wie es eben skizziert habe doch sehr
schwierigen fall über das
sachverständigen gutachten das zu lösen
und in der konstellation ist was
passiert was eigentlich mit dem
verfahren nicht selbst nichts zu tun hat
was aber finde ich schon wichtige rolle
ist mit dem mit dem vergleich der jetzt
auf dem tisch liegt nämlich andreas tilp
der wahrscheinlich in deutschland
anerkannteste
kapitalanlagerecht dafür hier vertreter
der der kapitalanleger ist tödlich
verunglückt anfang dieses jahres im
april und dann haben sich die
verbliebenen anwälte seiner kanzlei die
anderen partner doch über den sommer
hinweg sehr intensiv mit dem telekom
anmelden auseinandergesetzt man hat die
position vergleichen wie weit liegen wir
dann eigentlich noch auseinander und hat
dann offenbar ohne dass man das auch
große öffentlichkeit mitbekommen hat an
einem vergleichsvorschlag
gearbeitet und da auch wieder ein großes
problem dieses kapmug normalerweise ist
es ja so dass man im zivilprozess immer
darauf trinkt als richter eine einigung
gütliche einigung zu erzielen und
gleichzeitig haben es die parteien ja in
der hand aus dem prozess zu beenden das
ist bei diesem kapmug das damals noch
nach der allerersten form gilt er galt
nicht möglich sein musste und konzepte
und konzept wenn man erarbeitet hat
nochmal dem gericht vorstellen
beibringen und sich tatsächlich nochmal
physisch zusammentreffen und darüber
kürzlich austauschen anstatt die sache
jetzt schnell vom tisch zu wischen und
genau das war letzte woche der fall
beide seiten haben also einen sehr
vernünftigen sehr pragmatischen
vorschlag gebracht die telekom hat ein
deutliches zugeständnis gemacht um die
sachen zu beenden muss jetzt klar sagen
nicht das musterverfahren als solches
wird jetzt erst mal enden sondern sinn
und zweck dieses konzept das dem tisch
liegt ist diese 17.000 einzelklagen zu
beenden man hat also gesagt man guckt
sich an was haben die leute damals im
jahr 2000 ausgegeben konkret dafür
diesen erwerbspreis soll die leute
bekommen man muss sich aber auch das
kennen wir beispielsweise aus den deal
klagen das anrechnen lassen was man
zwischenzeitlich bekommen hat das kann
also konkrete sein dividendenzahlung
dieses jahr von den letzten 20 jahren
immer wieder gab oder natürlich wenn man
die aktien weiter verkauft hat muss man
sich möglicherweise ein gewinner
anrechnen lassen aber höchst attraktiv
für die bis zu 17.000 kläger ist das
prozesszinsen die ja nun mal teilweise
seit 20 jahren anlaufen gezahlt werden
in höhe von 70 prozent und man kriegt
seine anwaltskosten erstattet das ist
ein für die kläger sehr attraktives
angebot das der jetzt auf dem tisch
liegt und das wird man jetzt den
einzelnen klägern bis sommer nächsten
jahres unterbreiten vielleicht noch eine
kurze erklärung zu den prozesszinsen die
sind ja durchaus üblich und da sagt aber
die
wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe die
deutsche telekom die würden wir jetzt
nicht alle erstatten sondern 70 prozent
davon also nur ein teil und das wird
dann aber trotzdem das ist ja das
interessante das summiert sich dann auf
eine summe wahrscheinlich für die man je
nachdem wie viel man gekauft hat sich
meine so gibt es eigentlich so einen
durchschnittlichen bestand das einte das
wirkliche relevante datum ist dann hab
ich die klage eingereicht waren es die
dem dem dem beklagten der spricht der
telekom zu gestellt worden wenn ich
natürlich zu der ersten gruppe gehört
habe im april
2001 dann ist die zugestellt worden dann
ist die sogenannte rechtshändigkeit
vielleicht ab sommer 2001 schon gegeben
dann reden wir jetzt über den zeitraum
der zeit über 20 jahren ist und dieser
prozess ins der orientiert sich im
grunde nach hinter basel nach dem
basiszins der ein bisschen variieren
kann aber dann reden wir nochmal on top
von ein paar punkte drauf legen und dann
können da hohe einstellige prozent
zinsen anfallen und in einem
kapitalanlage umfeld wo wir mittlerweile
auf sparbücher vielleicht tatsächlich
nur noch um 0,1 prozent sind bekommen
dass man die relation gesetzt ist das
natürlich eine hohe summe die ihren job
auf die eigentlichen forderung nummer
drauf auch ehrlich gesagt ganz lustig
also die die aktion selber hat nicht
geformt aber das wird dann eben über die
prozesszinsen reingeholt das quasi die
rendite die man sich erhoffte der 1er
etwas alles zinsgeschäft wie gesagt die
einzelnen kläger bekommen ihr angebot
das es auch festgesetzt bis zum juni
nächsten jahres die telekom spielt das
aus über die jeweiligen prozess anwälte
die werden damit ihren mann dann in
verbindung setzen und dann ist dieses
kapitel auf der ebene vielleicht im
sommer kommenden jahres also knapp
ziemlich auf den tag genau 22 jahre nach
dem eigentlichen börsengang mutmaßt
beendet kurze abschluss noch auch die
erbengemeinschaft des musterklägers hat
laut aussage deren anwälten in dem
prozess schon signalisiert diesen sehr
attraktiven vergleichs konzept
zuzustimmen damit würde dann auch
wahrscheinlich das musterverfahren das
mit am längsten gelaufen es in
deutschland endlich auch enden
ihre also wirklich ein ganz ihres
verfahren was am anfang natürlich
wahnsinnig in der öffentlichkeit stand
dann in den vergangenen jahren dann also
doch er quasi etwas war für
feinschmecker und für die kenner der
materie also ist aber wirklich doch so
ein kapitel der deutschen
rechtsgeschichte dass ein so ein
bisschen fassungslos macht insbesondere
weil es wieder mal zeigt wie die
rechtlichen rahmenbedingungen eigentlich
nicht stimmen in deutschland dass man da
als kläger als lehrerin immer wieder an
grenzen stößt die man vielleicht besser
besser organisieren könnte es ist ein
reaktor das thema wiederum weil wir das
in den
koalitionsvereinbarungen beziehungsweise
vertrag aussehen werden dass man im
rahmen kollektiven rechtsschutz hinter
auch mehr in richtung gruppen und
sammelklagen gehen möchte auch die
eu-kommission drückt natürlich drauf und
da als absolut auch im kapitalmarktrecht
ein wahnsinniger vormittag
und wir waren bei anwälten und bleiben
jetzt bei den anwälten was tut sich da
an der gehalts front bringen wir eine
menge corinna nach einer wirklichen
sagen depression aber an eine
zwischenphase in der korona pandemie die
gehalts schrauben oder die spiralen
vielmehr in den großen
wirtschaftskanzleien die sich nochmal
nach oben geschraubt wir erinnern uns
geredet also über einen
arbeitsmarkt der letztendlich so von den
160 1000 zugelassenen anwälten die es in
deutschland gibt vielleicht in der summe
tatsächlich
glücklich und eine summe unter 10.000
anwälte betrifft und jeder sie nicht
spitzer markt in wahnsinnig spitzer
markt und da die insgesamt die
zahlen der abgänger von den
universitäten und auch die das zweite
staatsexamen machen eher zurückgehen
auch im zusammenhang mit dem
demographischen wandel aber weil das
beruf sich sich wandelt das des juristen
wird diese schere nicht breiter also es
gibt nicht ein größeres angebot an
interessanten bewerbern es verengt sich
immer mehr und dann stellen sich
natürlich aus sicht der arbeitgeber eine
frage wie mache ich mich attraktiver wie
kann ich mich in dem so genannten jetzt
muss ich aufpassen weil mein früherer
chef den ich bei der gelegenheit kurz
grüßen will und daher auch bei lisa ist
da immer auch drauf bin so genannten wo
vor talent
nicht im plural seinem wurf vor zellen
sich da positionieren will der kann das
nicht nur über die marke der kann das
nicht immer interessanter mandate
sondern im erster schritt ist natürlich
erstmal unterscheidungskriterium wieviel
bietet mir ein künftiger arbeitgeber in
der kanzlei
da müssen wir kurz einschieben weil sich
jetzt leute wahrscheinlich fragen wir
dann ehemaliger chef von
you war von dem jubel rechts markt dass
es
ein branchenmagazin für ein spiel hätte
und das natürlich bei den
wirtschaftsanwälten sehr beliebte
deswegen kennst du dich in dem markt
auch so gut aus weil du drei jahre lang
arbeitet
genau dargelegt
und jetzt erzähl doch mal um welches
über welche summen reden wir denn jetzt
hier also wir reden über summen die
wirklich auf dem tisch liegen das ist
deutschen nachwuchsjuristen mit der
sogenannten wie wir juristen ist einen
vollen kriegsbemalung das ist also ein
doppel voll befriedigend ein promotion
gegebenenfalls aber auch einen job auch
noch mal eine auslandserfahrung die
dokumentiert ist durch einen ll.m es
ermöglicht bis zu
160000 euro im ersten jahr zu verdienen
160000 brutto im jahr kann ja auch ich
sage da reden wir über leute die
teilweise wenn sie g8 hatten oder kein
freiwilliges soziales jahr gemacht da
reden wir über jahrgänge das ist möglich
dass mit 24 25 jahren zu verdienen
ja und das ist tatsächlich auch das was
viele erfahrene juristen oder auch
frühere großkanzler anwälte die dann
auch auf die inhouse zu sprechen die
unternehmen gewechselt hinter den
behörden oder vor allem auf die richter
seine gesten sind nur mit kopfschütteln
einfach sehen wie sich da die gehälter
entwickeln wenn eine kleine hausnummer
ich habe da mal überschlagen dass sich
das im mittel
das einstiegsgerät der der sogenannten
social jetzt im ersten jahr innerhalb
der letzten 15 jahre um mittlerweile
fast 50 prozent erhöht hat also wo man
früher gesagt hat wo ist was geißler
limit wer zahlt jetzt 100.000 ist
hunderttausend mittlerweile ein gewisser
standard in den großkanzleien wir können
es auch ein bisschen differenzieren noch
mal wenn du willst wer da wo zahlt der
die aktion entwicklung sehen so aus dass
wir eigentlich schon vorausgesehen haben
diejenigen die nach oben hinaus reisen
sind erst mal vor allem die anglo
amerikanischen wirtschaftskanzleien das
hat man auch in anderen größeren anwalts
märkten schon gesehen da guckt man ja
vor allen dingen mal was passiert in
amerika aber aus europäischer
kontinentaleuropäische ist ich gucke man
erstmal man auch noch nach london
da hat man gesehen dass die
amerikanischen kanzlei wollen die die
transaktions kanzleien deutlich nach
oben gegangen sind mit ihren gehältern
und damit auch die klassischen
britischen kanzleien immens und
umgesetzt haben das ist in deutschland
auch passiert nachdem in 2009 10 doch so
genannte fries es gab also aussetzung
von gehalts runden oder anpassungen von
von käfern
einstiegsgehältern haben im sommer die
ersten kleineren us kanzleien in
deutschland die vor allen dingen in
frankfurt aber auch in münchen sitzen
das sind kanzleien wie ein paar namens
in den körpern ellesmere bank aber
natürlich auch
alles kanzleien die sehr konzentriert
sind auf bestimmte hoch profitablen
bereich wie im modell private equity
sind hochgezogen da war eben die haus
namentlich genannt hat mir bank
beispielsweise die 160000 euro
angekündigt haben als einstiegsgehalt im
frühsommer dann hat sich natürlich jeder
gefragt wie geht das weiter und wir
sehen jetzt die reaktion im letzten
quartal diesen jahres warum ist das so
viele kanzleien setzten sich natürlich
jetzt hin machen ihre budgetplanung für
das kommende kalenderjahr fragen sich wo
müssen wir wie welche leute einstellen
ermitteln da sind damit ermitteln sich
natürlich auch der größte kostenblock in
einer kanzlerin da sind nun mal neben
den mieten auch die personalkosten und
die gehen nur einen weg nach nämlich
nach oben deuten und bevor man jetzt vor
neid erblasst muss man ehrlicherweise
auch sagen da wird geknüppelt ohne ende
also da gibt mir eigentlich sein
privatleben an der garderobe ab ja gut
ich möchte viele schauen ja gerne so
sehr wie sjuts indira so ein bisschen
auch qualifiziert wird dieses harte
arbeiten und dass man einfach zu den
großer seines privatlebens in seiner
kanzlei verbringt wir hatten das ja
schon vor langer langer zeit als
constantin noch horst war ja schon mal
so ein bisschen angespannt es ist
einfach so dass man sich wenn man einer
großkanzlei sich von der großkanzlei
entscheidet sich klar sein muss dass man
da bestimmte
zeiten einfach mehr arbeiten wird da
gibt es eben keine 9 bis 17 uhr
schichten
sondern ermittlung auch von den bereits
erwähnten früher und kollegen vom
hiervon juli zeigen
dass es in deutschland wirklich
kanzleien gibt die für ein junges jetzt
erwarten dass sie
70 bis 80 oder auch noch mehr stunden
pro woche arbeiten das muss man sich
einfach klarmachen wenn man über andere
arbeitsverhältnisse rede die über ein
tarifvertrag vielleicht regelt sind mit
38 stunden bruch oder auch 40 das gibt
es in diesem kanzlei nicht und das ist
auch irgendwie die downside der
geschichte welche die sich die sich die
sich da hinsetzen und sagen wie viel
bleibt mir dann von diesen 160000
eigentlich runtergerechnet
runtergebrochen auf seine arbeit übrig
und es gibt ganz die zahlreichen geht
dann einfach dabei landen dass man dann
im endeffekt pro stunde doch nur in
anführungszeichen 40 stunden 40 euro
brutto pro stunde verdient sollte solche
rechnungen muss man aber auch immer
kritisch hinterfragen ja ich weiß gerade
sagen da hat denn der tag vielleicht
auch mehr als 24 stunden also ich weiß
jetzt möchte ich nicht selber schlagen
aber jedenfalls wie gesagt die behören
und hörer da muss man vielleicht gar
nicht verneint ablassen
sondern kann es ihm als interessantes
phänomen mal zur kenntnis nehmen und
sagt sich der markt wird schon regeln
man muss gleich zum abschluss aber sagen
ich habe viel über die elf amerikaner
gesprochen aber der fairness halber die
neuentwicklung ist ja dass die großen
deutschen kanzler nachziehen eben mit
gleiss lutz die erhöhen auf 140 bis
250.000 euro das ist ein viertel mehr
als die vorher gezahlt haben auch
hengeler mueller nahezu zeitgleich zieht
nach geht auch auf die ähnliche summe
hoch sogar mit einem boni den gibt's
bald klar ist nicht verspielt hat auch
reagiert und auch cms immerhin die
größte deutsche kanzlerin nach den
köpfen in deutschland wo über 600 an
welt arbeiten erhöht auch ihre halter
auf eine etwas andere niveau aber auch
deutlich im vergleich zu vor wie schon
gesagt die gehälter am deutschen kanzlei
markt kennen nur eine richtung die gehen
deutlich nach oben ja gut dann lassen
wir das mal so stehen
[Musik]
und kommen jetzt noch zu einem nachtrag
wir hatten uns ja vor einigen wochen in
folge 183
über einen wirklich fürchterlichen fall
aus dem irak
unterhalten wo ein jüdisches mädchen
zu tode gefoltert wurde von einem
ehepaar muss man sagen dass in diesem
haus lebte das mädchen mit ihrer mutter
wurde da als haussklavin gehalten und
zur bestrafung wurde sie einmal nach
draußen in die sengende hitze
gestellt wurde festgebunden und ist dann
wirklich ganz jämmerlich gestorben und
wir hatten vor ein paar wochen eben von
183 schon mal über das urteil gegen die
frau gegen ein
deutsches
kämpferin gesprochen und nun hat das
oberlandesgericht frankfurt am main auch
den ehemann
verurteilt einen
29-jährigen es kämpfer und der hat
lebenslang bekommen wegen völkermordes
in tateinheit mit
verbrechen gegen die menschlichkeit mit
todesfolge einem kriegsverbrechen gegen
personen mit todesfolge beihilfe zu
einem kriegsverbrechen und
körperverletzung mit todesfolge also es
war wirklich eine ganze latte er wurde
zu lebenslanger freiheitsstrafe
verurteilt und muss ein schmerzensgeld
zahlen von
50.000 euro an die mutter des mädchens
das da verstorben was ich aus
rechtlicher sicht also das ist ein
unfassbares verbrechen was da passiert
ist was aus rechtlicher sicht aber noch
wirklich relevant ist es halt auch die
vertreter der bundesanwaltschaft nach
dem termin in frankfurt gesagt das ist
ein klares signal dass gesendet wird
dass man solche verfahren
in denen die die taten nicht in
deutschland stattfinden nicht begangen
werden von von deutsch staatsbehörden
dennoch auch hier in deutschland
strafrechtlich folgen auch warnten auch
vor gericht bringen kann das sind ganz
wichtiger punkt glaube ich an dem fall
denn man sieht auch gleich die reaktion
die beispielsweise heute aus den
niederlanden auch kam wir sind am
mittwoch also quasi einen tag zeichnet
auch nach dieser entscheidung aus
niederen kommen ganz klare signale dass
man diese entscheidung als erfolg mit
großem interesse verfolgte und ähnliche
gelagerte fälle auch dort vor den
irischen strafgerichten wir verfolgen
und auch zur verurteilung bringen das
ist ein wirklich bemerkenswerte
entwicklung in dieser ganzen situation
ja man muss eben sagen dass das
oberlandesgericht genau dieses signal
senden wollte also wer möchte kann sich
auch wirklich gerne nochmal die
pressemitteilung
anschauen die wirklich sehr sehr
ausführlich ist auch für so ein also für
so ein urteil generell relativ
ausführlich jetzt zieht sich über
mehrere seiten und es wird wirklich so
also sehr weit ausgeholt und auch noch
einmal die zusammenhänge geschildert
auch das leben was dieses kämpfer
geführt haben mit welcher brutalität
eben nicht nur dieses mädchen und auch
die mutter
verfolgt wurden oder behandelt wurden
sondern auch was die e s kämpfer
generell vor ort anrichten also das ist
wirklich ein ganz ganz erschüttern der
befund dass der situation da wird viel
unmenschliches und abscheuliches
geschildert das kann man sich vielleicht
mal deutlich machen und daneben liege so
wie du schon sagtest das urteil gegen
einen mann der ja eigentlich gar keinen
bezug zu deutschland hat übrigens anders
als seine frau jennifer die war ja
deutsche aber auch solche menschen
müssen sich hier in deutschland
verantworten für ihre taten die sie
womöglich ganz woanders begangen haben
kein leichtes thema genau aber um zu
überzuleiten auf den nächsten und
letzten punkt dieser sendung ein sehr
sehr gerechtes urteil das das
oberlandesgericht hatten in der tat das
hätte auch unser gerechtes urteil sein
können aber wir haben noch ein anderes
im petto
ja und diesmal geht es um das schnöde
kurzarbeitergeld wirklich nach diesem
nach diesen wirklich fassungslos machen
den schilderungen aus dem irak kommen
wir jetzt zu den niederungen die uns die
korona pandemie hier in deutschland
beschert da geht es letztendlich um die
frage der kurzarbeit die wir seit beginn
der pandemie immer stärker sehen also
immer noch sehen sagen wir so am anfang
sehr sehr stark daran hat sich
zwischendrin ein bisschen abgenommen
jetzt sagt die bundesagentur für arbeit
wider dass sich das wohl in den nächsten
monaten wieder verstärken wird da kommen
wir zu der frage ob man denn
tatsächlich urlaubsansprüche hat obwohl
man auf kurzarbeit null gesetzt wurde
also obwohl man gar nicht arbeiten muss
und trotzdem geld erhält vom staat
also das ist tatsächlich die
gäste neben den beschlüssen des
bundesverfassungsgericht eigentlich die
zweite große relevante entscheidungen im
zusammenhang mit den crooner maßnahmen
in dem fall astes jahr schon erwähnt das
sehr starke nutzen mittel der kurzarbeit
und ist auch finde ich gestern in der
ganzen beschlusslage in karlsruhe ein
bisschen übersteuern ist extrem wichtig
wir reden also hier über ein präsident
fall der aber mutmaßlich 10.000 von
arbeitnehmerinnen und arbeitnehmer in
deutschland betrifft
kurze hausnummer für das
kurzarbeitergeld sind deutlich über 40
milliarden euro investiert worden so wir
reden dann ausgezahlt worden an dem
unternehmen also eine ganz relevante
summe und wie du schon gesagt hast ist
die auswirkungen auf kurzarbeiter
kurzarbeit null gestellt wird auf die
urlaubsansprüche was wenn die relevanz
hat das der fall über den wir in erfurt
jetzt sprechen gespielt in
nordrhein-westfalen genauer gesagt geht
es um eine verkäuferin aus essen die hat
statt der 14 tage die ihr als
verkaufshilfe bei einer arbeitszeit von
drei arbeitstagen wöchentlich eigentlich
zustanden von 14 tagen wegen dieser über
monate hinweg dann da und kurzarbeit
null im vergangenen jahr nur
11,5 tage bekommen und mit dieser klage
vor den arbeitsgerichten wollte sie
unterstützt durch den rechtsschutz des
deutschen gewerkschaftsbundes eben diese
25 zusätzliche urlaubstage zugesprochen
bekommen in den vorinstanzen saß schon
schlecht aus sowohl im ersten als auch
beim landesarbeitsgericht in düsseldorf
die haben die klagen jeweils abgewiesen
weil man ja immer dann auch argumentiert
hat naja in der zeit in der du aufgrund
der kurzarbeit null im keine
arbeitspflicht hat ist kann auch keinen
tatsächlich urlaubsanspruch erworben
werden denn das ist ein grundsatz im
arbeitsrecht man erwirbt nicht nur den
lohn durch seine arbeit sondern es gibt
natürlich auch eine weitere leistung die
der arbeitgeber dann dem arbeitnehmer
bewilligt nämlich den urlaubsanspruch
den er wirkt sehr durch deine arbeit und
so haben die richter in vorinstanzen
argumentiert der kann natürlich auch
anteilig nicht gewährt werden sprich
gekürzt werden genau das vielleicht
einfach noch mal deutlich zu machen weil
es ja wenn man das wenn du das so da
legst es ist ja ein bisschen so einen
brenner dass man irgendwie so denkt na
ja wie kommt diese frau eigentlich
darauf dass man wenn man sowieso nicht
arbeitet auch noch urlaub dafür bekommt
dass man nicht arbeitet das ist ja
irgendwie ehrlich gesagt eine paradoxe
situation
und das müsste man vielleicht einfach
mal erklären wo quasi die ungenauigkeit
war oder die unklarheit und warum es
tatsächlich bis zum bundesarbeitsgericht
gehen musste um das zu klären und da
muss man eben einfach sagen dass der
erholungsurlaub ist ja verankert im
bundesurlaubsgesetz in § 1 und 3 1 der
paragraf eins und drei und da es knüpft
normalerweise eben allein annes bestehen
des arbeitsverhältnisses anderer und
dann gibt es irgendwie
also situation wo zum beispiel jemanden
ganzes jahr krank ist also auch nicht
arbeitet und man in solchen situationen
aber sagt selbstverständlich hat er
trotzdem
ein anspruch auf urlaub ja also der
arbeitnehmer die arbeitnehmerin die da
unverschuldet krank geworden ist die
sich krank schreiben lassen musste
kranken natürlich trotzdem ihren urlaub
bekommen so dann gibt es andere
situationen wo zb das arbeitsverhältnis
ruht wegen eines sabbaticals und da gibt
es diesen erholungs anspruch nicht darf
daneben anteilig gekürzt werden und
deswegen bestand eben bei dieser frage
der die unsicherheit ja wozu zählt denn
jetzt nun eigentlich dass die kurzarbeit
ja die das ist gesetzlich nicht geregelt
und da hat jetzt eben das
bundesarbeitsgericht und wie wir finden
sehr gerecht festgestellt also auch in
diesem fall darf es gekürzt werden aber
weil es eben keine gesetzliche regelung
gab brauchte es eben die klarstellung
durch das bundesarbeitsgericht das brg
hat sich in dem fall orientiert an der
folge für urteile das gab gewissermaßen
der rechtssprechung des europäischen
gerichtshof dass da die schranken
vorgegeben hat aber wie du eben schon
gesagt hast seit 2009 10 gab es mehrere
urteile des bundesarbeitsgerichts dass
ich mit dem fragen zu den sogenannten
verringere den urlaubsanspruch
beschäftigen musste und es hat immer
bejaht dass eine verringerung oder
kürzungen durch den arbeitgeber
möglichst eben in den fällen beim
unbezahlten sonderurlaub oder bei
malters zahlst modellen
altersteilzeitmodellen wo es aber eben
gerade noch keine regelung gab weil wir
eben keine pandemie bislang in diesem
umfeld in diesem ausmaß hatten in
deutschland und weil ihm das
kurzarbeitergeld in diesem ausmaß
bislang noch nicht fallen runter auf 0
noch nicht so eine große rolle gespielt
hat in der deutschen wirtschaft gab es
einfach diese notwendigkeit das mal zu
klären und damit hat erfurt jetzt
zumindest aus sicht der vielen den
klagen der betroffenen
kurzarbeiter eine entscheidung getroffen
die nicht schmecken wird die aber
dogmatisch richtiges muss man einfach
sagen und damit wahrscheinlich auch
heute unser gebet und ehrlich gesagt
auch vom nicht nur dogmatisch sondern
auch vom vom lebensgefühl her oder also
ich meine wirklich bei aller liebe aber
dann jetzt auch noch urlaub zur
beanspruchung für die zeit finde ich
schon
einfach also das ist ja auch eine
belastung für den unternehmer na das
darf man jetzt auch nicht vergessen in
diesem fall sind ja auch nicht immer ein
großunternehmer sondern eine
unternehmerin sondern eben auch ganz
viele kleine arbeitgeber also da muss
man schon ein bisschen die kirche im
dorf lassen also deswegen ein sehr
gerechtes urteil der woche
so und dann kommen wir jetzt aber zum
ende
und ich danke lieber markus hier für
deinen einsatz an der jura front hat mir
große freude bereitet vielen dank für
die einladung dass ich mal wieder hier
sprechen könnte das ist eine
pickepackevoll sendung gewesen mit einem
wirklich sehr spannen interview mit
professor meyer zu den beschlüssen wir
haben das bgh-urteil eben noch mal kurz
skizziert das eine große relevanz hat
für den arbeitsmarkt vermutlich aber
auch darauf hinweist wo es jetzt in den
kommenden winter wieder hingeht und
sicherlich auch für den einen oder
anderen jüngeren hörer der sich momentan
gedanken macht in einer großkanzlei
anzufangen eine kleine orientierung
geben danke und ich wünsche allen hörern
eine schöne woche und die auch natürlich
könne es auch bald herzlichen dank für
die aufmerksamkeit bis nächste woche
geht's
[Musik]